This is Jocko podcast number 46 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
There is a little survival instinct.
It's,
it's very subtle,
but I would notice it sometimes in a combat situation.
Okay.
When guys are thinking that enemy fire at any time could open up
and kill them,
you'd see some guys subconsciously,
they just did just try and make themselves a little bit of a smaller target.
It just Kinda slouched their backs down a little bit and they just kind of bow
their head just a tad.
Okay.
It's not a,
it's not a bad thing to do.
I don't think guys actually think about it.
I don't think they consciously do it.
I think it just kinda happens.
Make it happens when you think you could get shot at any moment
ready.
It's likely a good instinct to have
in.
When we first got to Ramadi,
we were out on patrol and I saw one of my guys on a real patrols my first time
seeing this particular guy on a real patrol,
and it was in the [inaudible] district of Ramadi,
which was just an enemy controlled cesspool of violence
with threats everywhere.
And as I saw this guy,
he was standing straight up,
just standing straight up.
His head was held high as a weapon was at the ready.
He was scamming,
he was hunting.
There was no slouch in his back,
there was no lowering of his head.
There was no fear apparent on his face or in his posture.
He was just boldly facing the threat
standing tall.
Now you've heard me talk about some of my guys in task unit bruiser
that I worried about
are just some of the guys I,
I thought that they basically had too much courage,
too much bravery and it,
and it just didn't seem like that kind of attitude
was survivable day after day after day after bloody day in Ramadi,
but somehow some way through some divine providence,
this particular brave soul did survive and actually thrived in that environment.
In the battle of Ramadi with task unit bruiser.
Yup.
Tasking,
a bruiser was made up of two seal platoons,
Charlie Petunia and Delta Platoon Charlie Batoon we've talked about before.
Leif Babin was the platoon commander,
Tonia fratty who's been on the podcast BTF Tony.
He was the platoon chief and the lead sniper for Charlie platoon was was Chris
Kyle
and in the other platoon Delta platoon where Andrew Paul,
who's also been on the podcast,
he was the assistant platoon commander
and the point man and sniper.
The lead point man and lead sniper for Delta platoon was,
was that guy was the guy that I just described walking through the literal
valley of death
with his head held high
and his name is Jeremiah Danelle.
Yeah.
Also known as j p Denelle.
That's what I always called him
and we have him as a guest on the podcast tonight.
Now
when JP was in tasking at bruiser,
he was a kid when we,
when we were in workup,
I think he was 22 years old when we deployed.
He was 23 years old and I love Jp.
He was like a brother and to be quite honest with you,
it's like a little brother to me.
And I loved his aggressiveness and when we were going through workup,
he would just,
just straight up execute anything.
I told him to do anything
like a,
like a hyper aggressive terminator robot.
I will look at him and say,
JP,
take that room or JP get on that high ground or JP get those prisoners out of
here and he would just get after it and make it happen and just destroy your
outmaneuver.
Anything that was in his way?
Well,
one
time we were going through mount training,
which is urban warfare,
so we're in kind of a fake city with buildings and all this and there was a
building across the street and we were taking massive pink ball fire.
Again,
it's just training,
but we're getting shot up with paint ball.
Yeah,
and in my mind I'm thinking,
okay,
we're where if this is real,
we're getting killed and I know that we need to get aggressive to stop this and
say I'm kind of give the command of,
hey,
we need to hit that building across the street.
And it like,
as the last word is coming out of my mouth,
I see JP just bust out of the door,
the building we're in,
just go running across the street with his gun blazing.
Just caveman smashed through the door of the target building.
You goes in there and I just see muzzle flashes.
He's just machine gunning people
and I thought to myself,
okay,
yeah,
j p can bring it.
At least he can bring it during training
because courage against paint ball in training is actually not that big of a
deal at all.
In fact,
it's borderline meaningless,
but it is an indication.
Now,
courage in sustained combat is another thing.
And J P proved himself as a true warrior over and over and over again during the
battle of Ramadi.
Great.
I'm honored to have my brother
Jp Tyndale on the podcast today.
JP,
welcome to the show.
Thank you for having me here.
And we have to start with trying to understand
where are you come from,
how much time do we have,
where you grew up and,
and all that.
And it's pretty cool.
I mean,
I know,
I know your mom and dad and I've actually grappled against your dad.
Yeah.
It's one of his highlights.
He loves that.
He talks about it all the time.
What's wrong?
Strong man.
Scary.
Strong.
Yeah.
Like what and how will,
so how old is he now?
Um,
he is 54 55.
No kidding.
Yeah.
So 10 years ago he was my age.
So what I grappled with him,
he was my age.
Yeah.
And I thought he was all old now and right now if you call me old,
I'd be pissed.
Yeah,
I know you would be.
So Mr Denelle,
I apologize.
I thought you were all back in the day.
Nope.
He grabbed a hold of my head.
They were in line with that.
I am right now.
Oh,
that's crazy,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Sorry to interrupt.
Yeah,
no,
that's true.